la beauté et l'actualité
marlyse la veine bas pour les fêtes de
noël et du nouvel an elles veulent être
très spécialement belle
jacqueline chorale marie peysson
jacqueline huet et catherine langeais
ont un rendez-vous avec leur famille
avec leurs amis mais surtout avec vous
téléspectateurs à qui elles consacreront
une partie de leur temps c'est pour cela
que jacqueline cora comme ses amis
étudie la coiffure qu'elle adoptera pour
les fêtes
elle a hésité entre une coiffure courte
à peu ronflante agrémenté d'un gros
bijoux fantaisie la voici
et une coiffure plus inattendu qui fait
appel à une grosse nat postiches posée
en couronne sur la tête
à vous de décider
postiches et bijoux fantaisie sont les
deux grands succès de la coiffure cette
année jacqueline huet comme toutes les
femmes a été séduite par ces deux idées
postiches pour ses coiffures très
étudiés où la nappe donne au chignon une
élégance toute particulière bijoux pour
sa coiffure presque habituelle c'est un
grand nom de velours piqué d'un strass
et cela donne un air de fête
anne marie peysson est un peu inquiète
sa mèche postiches aurait tendance à se
poser à la gare beau et cela lui semble
peu pratique
mais elle est rasséréné lorsqu'elle voit
cette coiffure sage et très seyante à
grosse quiche asymétrique
mais peut-être la préférez-vous avec ce
chignon de boucles le miracle réalisé
par les coiffeurs et de réussir sur
cheveux courts des effets si
dissemblables
anne-marie qui aime bien changé de
coiffure est ravi coiffures courtes
mousseuse comme du champagne pour
catherine langeais la frange et effilées
et les mèches qui encadrent son visage
sont légères
mais elle n'échappera pas à la tentation
du postiches parce qu'il donne aux
coiffures habituel un air de vacances
quant aux bijoux fantaisie il a ici le
double rôle de mettre en valeur la
coiffure et de souligner le décolleté c4
coiffure ces quatre visages sont votre
sourire de noël
trois jours